Venezuela's main Consulate in Colombia's
capital Bogota lies in Ruins an
accidental fire in April burned much of
it its walls covered in graffiti and
overgrown weeds it's a tangible symbol
of a relationship gone sour since 2019
when Colombia's former president Ivan
Duke refused to recognize Nicolas Maduro
as the president of Venezuela after
elections Duca said were fraudulent
but all that has changed with the
election of Colombia's first leftist
president Gustavo Pedro who promised to
restore relations
last month Maduro enthusiastically
received Colombia's newly appointed
Ambassador emitting big on laughs and
hugs the Colombian invoice says the
neighbors should never have parted ways
there are some 5 million Colombian
citizens that have been totally
abandoned for years without possibility
to renew a passport and ID it was just
stupid and inhumane whatever the
difference is it doesn't make sense to
have no Communications
the two countries have since announced a
full reopening of their porous 2000
kilometers long border for trade
called for the resumption of military
collaboration in a region overrun by
criminal groups
but despite the many pledges and
boastful announcements restoring full
diplomatic relations is easier said than
done cut the two countries remain deeply
suspicious of one another
I think it will be a much more complex
and long process than what people think
the two countries have deeper symmetries
if you look at trade Venezuela's
industry is in shambles for the Maduro
regime the most important thing is to
show that they're not as isolated as
they were while Colombia had a lot to
gain economically but wants to avoid
being seen as cozing up to a less than
democratic government yeah rival of
Venezuelan Ambassador in Colombia was a
noticeable muted Affair and the
countries have so far avoided addressing
Venezuela's ongoing political crisis and
the fate of the more than 2.5 million
refugees in Colombia the agenda makes no
mention of security of migration of
consulate Services Venezuela's
Ambassador Placencia has long denied the
existence of a migratory crisis but now
that he's in Bogota he inevitably will
have to recognize it and address it but
even with its many fits and starts the
fact that the two neighbors are talking
again is welcome news for millions of
Colombians and Venezuelans on both sides
of the Border they've been in limbo for
years but now believe there's hope for a
more stable future Alessandra Al Jazeera
Bogota